on Friday the bureau of labor statistics
reported a major job spike of 235
thousand jobs in February dropping the
unemployment rates at four point seven
percent according to CNBC the good news
didn't stop there average hourly
earnings from two-point-eight percent on
an annualized basis construction jumped
by 58,000 jobs and manufacturing added
twenty eight thousand jobs the u6
unemployment rate which includes the
underemployed is now at a recent low of
nine point two percent probably 326,000
new full-time positions were added to
the market so why the boom analysts say
the Trump selection is indeed the reason
but it's not just president Trump's
election it's the fact that Republicans
hold Congress as well and are looking to
pare back regulations well the media
focused on from Twitter and facilities
the markets are far more focused on the
fact that a predictable economic
backdrop has finally been created for
the market now a few caveats the labor
force participation rates decreased in
febuary but it remains historically week
at just sixty-three percent we would
have to gain about 10 million new jobs
in order to maintain this unemployment
rate was the same labor force
participation rate we had in 2000 it is
important to recognize that despite the
weakness President Obama's economic
recovery Trump did inherit a growing
economy and one with significant
breakout potential you can't ignore the
same unemployment statistics you used
rip Obama and retain credibility you
can't cite the stock market as evidence
of Trumpy ingenious if you ignored it
for eight years under Obama Trump and
his allies have counted the stock market
jump since his election but the reality
is that the stock market boosted
significantly in continuously during the
Obama years President Obama's recovery
was the weakest in modern American
history but that's because his
job-killing regulations and penalties on
investment drove people to sock away
money and invest in stock buybacks
rather than investing in new research
and development or hiring so how robust
is the markets conference in Trump we'll
find out in the next few months as the
Federal Reserve hikes interest rates as
Congress struggles to move forward with
a tax restructuring will also find out
if the systemic problems plaguing the
job market new technology replacing jobs
the movement toward the service based
economy rather than manufacturing if it
somehow bucks all the long-term trends
for the last decade and a half that's
unlikely in the years to come there's no
question markets are more confident than
it has been for eight years because
finally they believe they won't be hit
over the head by an unexpected economic
sledgehammer from the left side of the
aisle I'm Ben Shapiro this is the ben
shapiro
show
I shouldn't note here by the way that
it's always very dangerous to talk about
attributing economic movements to
particular presidents or politics
because there is a lag effect you know
the fact is that President Reagan for
the first couple of years of his
administration at a very weak economy
that wasn't cuz Reagan that was because
the lag effect from Carter Bill Clinton
had a very strong economy when he came
into office that wasn't because it
Clinton that was because of a labs
effects from George HW Bush's economy so
to try and attribute all of the current
economic goings on Donald Trump is a
little bit overwrought I think that
consumer confidence is a lot higher
because of Trump I think that the
markets are optimistic because of Trump
the stock market particularly thinks
there's breakout potential but you know
everybody needs to hold off a little bit
before attributing all sorts of great
God genius to Trump because the markets
are doing great because the fact is it's
not quite that simple using these sorts
of metrics is what generates the fall
statistics you hear from Democrats all
the time about the idea that jobs do
better under Democrats which ignores
again that labs effect and also ignores
who's in control of Congress I think
that if the markets are in a comfortable
position is because they feel
comfortable then nobody's going to do
anything truly terrible to the market
right now but we'll talk more about that
in just a second plus that continued
failure of the rollout of Trump care but
first we have to say thank you so our
friends over at helix sleep so my wife
and I like helix leads so much that when
helix leave sent us a mattress and we
tried it out we actually dumped a more
expensive mattress moved it into the
other room because helix sleep
mattresses are so good so you go to
helix we calm and they ask you a series
of questions if you like to bed hard or
soft which side you like to sleep on how
you like to sleep do you like the
mattress to be sort of breathable or do
you like it to be warmer and then they
send you a mattress in the mail and if
you don't like it you can try out for a
hundred days if you don't like it then
they will you can send it right
back hundred percent refund no questions
asked it is fantastic just open the box
and inflates right in front of you
because the foam mattress and its really
good not only is good they also have
technology that allows them to using
using their proprietary algorithms they
can they can actually create a bet
that's Miller or specific to you and if
you have a spouse then it is specific to
both sides of the bed so you can have
different firmness or different
breathability in the mattress on the two
sides of the bed really they're
fantastic helix sweet calm you know I'm
somebody who doesn't tend to get as much
sleep as I should when I do sleep I want
to become
triple helix sleep makes that happen
helix leitrim slash spending at fifty
dollars off your order right now helix
fleetcom slash spending at fifty dollars
off your order it's also cheaper than
competitive marketing firms out there if
you end to a mattress store it's a lot
more expensive than going to helix leaps
calm and he looks which is better than
they are because it's personalized you
helix fleetcom / ben get fifty dollars
off your order helix sleep calm / ben
make sure you use the / fence that they
know that we sent you and also see you
get that discount okay so the big story
continues to be the rollout of Obamacare
repeal and replacement Ryan care Crump
care as I said yesterday i'm calling it
Trump care and the reason that i'm
calling a trump care is specifically
because we called it obamacare we didn't
call pelosi care or or you know the or
schumer care or or harry reid care it
was called obamacare seen novices chrome
care so there were a lot of chrome care
is going poorly the reason is going
poorly is because nobody is very
committed to this Trump hair replacement
bill because the bill isn't very good we
discussed all the problems with the bill
before Paul Ryan is the only one out
there really something for it because
Paul Ryan has the worst job in the
universe being speaker of the house with
a fractious Republican caucus is not an
easy job it's particularly not an EG
traveling you think that your job is to
pass things now this is something that
has bothered me for a long time the job
of Congress is not necessarily to pass
things in fact when Congress decides it
is imperative that they pass things
usually you end up with a craft hand
which of a bell what you really ought to
do is passed a bunch of little bills
like this is a business people have
asked me what's the constitutional
amendment that you would pursue if you
could pursue one I would say no bills
longer than three pages all in plain
English right that seems to me the way
to do the bill and it would be great if
there was like an explainer so instead
of all these bills have to be written in
legal language they'll say remove the
word in provision for D of this of this
separate section of the u.s. code it
would be great if there is an explainer
in the back and said here's what that
actually does you know that would be
useful and then Americans could actually
see what the representatives are doing
instead of having a 120 page bill dumped
on them with no notice and no
explanation and that there's a lot of
confusion because they keep saying it's
stage 1 and their stage 2 & 3 we don't
know what stages two and three are yeah
there's a bad way to do business and
it's disappointing to me that
Republicans keep participating in it
because they want to prove that
can get something done I'm less
interested in Congress doing something
that in Congress doing something good
but Paul Ryan was out there basically
making a presentation yesterday he
rolled up his sleeves and he did a
presentation that is the most
entertaining thing that you will see
anywhere outside of H&R Block because
Paul Ryan is basically a really boring
accountant so here's Paul Ryan talking
about the American Health Care Act which
is not the Affordable Care Act it's the
American Health Care Act and then he put
up a TV screen behind him any jabbered
about it for a bit we as Republicans
have been waiting seven years to do this
we as Republicans who fought the
creation of this law and accurately
predicted that it would not work ran for
office in 2010 in 2012 in 2014 and in
2016 on a promise that we would if given
the ability we would repeal and replace
this law how many people running for
Congress and the Senate did you hear say
that how many times if you hear a
president donald trump when he was
canada donald trump say that this is the
closest we will ever get to repealing
and replacing obamacare the time is here
the time is now this is the moment and
this is the closest this will ever
happen it really comes down to a binary
choice we now have the ability through
the budget rules that we have in the
Senate with our three-pronged approach
to actually make good on our word okay
here's what I hate and here's why I'm
groaning and grunting and making all
sorts of animal noises okay the reason
that I'm upset about this as I am very
very sick of Republicans telling us that
we have a binary choice it's always a
stupid damn binary choice to binary
choice is due to this bill or you get
obamacare it's either Trump or you get
Hillary it's always at least it with
Trump and Hillary there was an argument
because it actually is a binary election
but here you can propose any bill that
you possibly want right i mean here it
could be tons of different bills you can
probably do it the way I want it you do
a piecemeal you know a different bill
completely you go back to the drawing
board you can have a conciliation
meeting between Trump
and McConnell and Ryan and hash this
thing out you could have you could you
could just pass the repeal and not sin
replace there are tons of things you can
do i'm so tired of Republicans trying to
cram down crappy policy by saying it's
binary choices but it's either this or
the highway well guess what it isn't
guess what it isn't go back to the
drawing board and do better stop sucking
and when he talked about when Paul Ryan
says you know the Senate rules prevents
us from doing more than this because if
we do more than this and it violates the
Senate rules so use Mike Pence to
overrule the the committee rules chair
right the way that this works is that
reconciliation rules allow you to
reconciliation without having to meet
the 60-vote threshold reconciliation
rules allow you to mess around with the
specific provisions of Obamacare but
you're not supposed to go much beyond
that okay well if you don't like that
then you can either invoke the nuclear
option or you can just have Mike Pence
preside over the rules and overrule the
Senate chair when it comes to the rules
so no they're a bunch of different
options that happen here but again we
just keep hearing I'm sick of this
blackmail and sick of Republicans
blackmailing you from sick of
Republicans blackmailing me I'm sick of
this routine where it we came up with
this crap down in from the villain if
you don't get this you don't get
anything screw you you weren't for me
okay Paul Ryan works for me these
Congress people work for me and they
work for you and it's not their job to
tell you what options are on the table
all options are on the table because we
are the consumer we are the customer we
are the people who have right we are the
people who put these people in their job
we are the ones who create the job
description when I hire somebody at
daily wire I create the job description
they don't create the job description
Paul Ryan does not create his own job
description he doesn't get to tell me
what the options are if the options are
what we say they are and if we don't
like these options go pi get and go get
some new options I'm so sick of this and
the reasons think of this is because
again it's used to take conservatism and
throw it out by the side of the road and
then say well you know this is the best
we could do this is the best we could do
I've been living my entire life under
Republicans who say this is the best we
can do and very rarely is it the best
they can do usually it's just some sort
of crappy halfway bill that doesn't do
what it's supposed to do and leaves in
place most of the provisions the
Democrats get why is it when Democrats
get power they immediately ram through
bills that they love that their base
loves when Republicans get power they
immediately start trying to ram through
bills they think will make them more
political
popular and then they don't even succeed
in being politically popular it's so
stupid George W Bush did the same thing
he's a Medicare Part D you know this is
what you're going to get and then we did
it and to make George W Bush wildly
popular in win reelection in 2004 based
on Medicare Part D human reelection in
2004 based on the fact that he was a
wartime president if he was not a
wartime president very little doubt that
george w bush's losses in 2004 it wasn't
campaign finance reform that put him
over the top and it wasn't medicare part
d that put them over the top every
republican who does this routine where
they say well you know if we just do
this thing that's sort of half left ism
that's the best we can do why is that
always the best we can do it's so
frustrating and not only that now
they're trying to jam it through now
they're trying to jam it through okay so
here is Jim Acosta on CNN he's right
Paul Ryan is trying to jam this stupid
bill through that nobody likes seriously
nobody likes this bill the only people
who like this bill apparently our trump
and Ryan and Trump is escaping all
criticism because I know we have to be
very careful about president Trump we
must not offend the great one we must
never say anything bad about President
Trump we have to say that it's all on
Paul Ryan Donald Trump is behind this
thing Donald Trump wants this thing
Donald Trump wants this thing because
this thing is half left ism hey Donald
Trump is not a hardcore conservative
he's never been a hardcore conservative
particularly on this issue during the
campaign he basically came out at one
point for single-payer before walking it
back so this idea that this is all Paul
Ryan's fault is just a bunch of asinine
nonsense if Paul Ryan put in front of
him a bill that just repeals Obamacare
there's no guarantee the Trump would
actually sign it because he'd be afraid
that there'd be blowback for all the
people who would quote will lose their
insurance under Medicaid from from
Obamacare the White House press
secretary Sean Spicer saying we're not
jamming this bill through this health
care bill through well when you have
committees working almost through the
night when you have members of Congress
being asked to weigh in on a proposal
that has not been scored by the
Congressional Budget Office I think you
would have a lot of people up on Capitol
and also by the way you have a lot of
the stakeholders that were involved in
the formulation of Obamacare doctors
hospitals and so on they really have not
been part of this process that that
pretty much beats the definition of
jamming things through Brooke so the
White House may be saying we're not
jamming it through
but they are jamming it through at this
point there they want this on a fast
track because they know how incredibly
difficult this is going to be with so
many CNN is wildly biased and they are
but in Jim Acosta is wildly biased and
he is but what are you saying here is
actually true ok buh-bah maker took a
year to roll out a year and there was
vast debate over which is why it almost
died is why Scott Brown ended up being a
senator in Massachusetts to replace Ted
Kennedy because the American people
didn't want Obamacare Democrats pushed
it through over the objections of the
American people and then they lost the
house and then they lost the Senate and
then they lost the presidency okay but
Republicans are jamming this thing
through they are it's been like two
weeks in this thing came out what on
Monday on Monday this thing came out and
they talking about voting on it I think
in two weeks three weeks and come on
come on an identity is garbage bill it's
filled with garbage it's just it's so
foolish on every level and it's not just
a casa saying it right Tom cotton is
saying people are upset we're jamming
this thing through I'm with the American
people and the promises I made to our
Kansans that we're going to reduce the
cost of their health care and make it
accessible and give them more control
over their health care choices look
there there are a lot of Republicans who
are saying these exact same things in
private frankly some of the months these
releases with team are saying the same
thing I'm simply saying in public what
many Republicans reversing that the
legislation as it's written one probably
cannot pass the Senate but but two would
not solve the problems of our health
care system problems that Obamacare made
worse I think the American people care
much more that we solve those problems
then that we meet some kind of arbitrary
legislative deadline okay and that's
exactly right what he's saying here is
exactly right Tom cotton by the way is a
major ally of president Trump so when he
says this what he's really doing is he's
preciate he's for staging what is
actually going to happen or what's
actually going to happen here is this
thing as going to go down in flames
Trump's going to blame everybody and
then we're going to get stuck with
Obamacare now I'm going to talk about
the dangers of that in just a second but
first we have to say thank you to our
sponsors over at the US concealed carry
association so if you're somebody who
worries deeply about your second
Amendment rights you want to make sure
that not only do you have the right to
conceal and carry but also do you have
the firearms education and training that
you need self-defense insurance they
make sure that if God forbid you have to
shoot somebody in self-defense they have
a legal apparatus that's available to
you because just because you did the
right thing doesn't mean that the legal
system won't come after you that's what
UFC CA is for and right now just done
straight you know how pro-gun they are
the US CCA is going to buy 10 of my
listeners at the gun of their dreams so
right now if you go to defend my family
now calm defend my family now calm you
can enter in what is basically a
sweepstakes ten chances to win $1,500
for any gun that you want no
restrictions you can pick any gun any
brand any caliber defend my family
now.com to enter super cool offer go
there and give them your information and
then you have a chance to win $1,500 for
any gun that you want ten chances
actually to win because there are 10
people who are going to get this thing
1500 bucks for anyone you want to spend
my family now calm again I don't think
there's any more important right in the
in the bill of rights in the Second
Amendment and you Seca makes sure that
the Second Amendment is upheld and you
have all the resources that you need in
order to ensure that the Second
Amendment maintains its power and
maintains its applicability to you and
your family the uscc a great
organization defend my family now.com to
enter defend my family now calm they are
changing the game for responsible gun
owners making sure they have all the
education care and protection that you
need to fend my family now calm for that
chance 1 15 hundred dollars toward a
toward a gun of your choice which is
super cool okay well I want to talk just
briefly here about the fact that this
thing probably will go down you know
then and what the plan is after this Oh
Rand Paul is also saying that this thing
is going to go down in flames here is
Rand Paul saying you know you basically
the Republicans have been fitting about
what's in this thing it is a conundrum
that's why we should vote on the one
thing that we all agreed on about a year
ago we voted on clean repeal we don't
agree on replacement but we could have a
separate vote on Medicaid expansion and
I'm guessing Democrats and big
government Republicans would probably
come together and find that they will
expand Medicaid many conservatives
aren't going to vote for that mainly
because it doesn't work we're we're
dishonest in the accounting we can't pay
for the current Medicare it's 35
trillion dollars in the hole the current
Medicaid is unfunded and then we're
going to add new entitlement programs to
that if you really want to have Medicaid
for everyone in all these states you
should be honest with the people and you
should double or triple the state income
tax and double or triple the the self
act now I'm not for that
that's what it would take if you were
honest instead we sell federal
government's going to pay for it federal
government has no money we borrow a
million dollars a minute so it's just
dishonest a cowl-neck a Senator Paul is
exactly right here and this is the
problem Republicans have decided they're
going to get in the ball game of more
efficient government and the
conservatism the new conservatism isn't
about less government is about more
efficient government with the same exact
mandate as the Democrats no no it's but
it's bound to fail and it should fail
now but this leaves is a backup strategy
and to hear about the backup strategy
which is going to be basically let
Obamacare stay in place we'll talk about
that but you have to be a subscriber
over at daily we're calm eight dollars a
month gets you the subscription today
lee weyer calm plus you get an annual
subscription you get a free copy of the
arroyo which is a free DVD copy of
fictional film set on the southern
border really compelling kind of an
old-school western sent on the southern
border the arroyo you get a copy of that
and obviously we're starting the shapiro
store pretty soon i assume that we will
be selling Michael moles number one
best-selling book reasons to vote
Democrat so that I assume that will be
part of the Shapiro store at some point
here but go to daily wire calm right now
subscribe plus you can be part of the
mailbag we're doing mailbag today and if
you want to send in your live questions
and have them answered and have your
life be made just incredibly great
because you had your question answered
by yours truly go to daily wire calm
right now and subscribe or to listen
later on iTunes or SoundCloud we are the
top conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
you